true news the sweet brian plans to cover
Oh still busy so so i prizes busy on his
he is running his own business he is an
entrepreneur if you want to make money
like us go hit the link in the
description before I took the piss out
of what you've done I don't actually
know how bad it is
there's a buck well we can take a look
after these messages hey you watching at
home you yes you yes yeah you you good
you probably already heard of red shadow
legends hello yeah well yeah of course
well if you hover yeah you are a lucky
boy yeah good point
or girl it's basically a really great
dark RPG fantasy game Brian I've broken
my leg for quite some time on your more
viable that's that's the kuia it's not
it's not on console now it's the best
damn mobile game you ever did see
but guess what it looks like it should
be on a console oh that's so great
that's the funny thing Brian it's not
only on mobile anymore it's also on PC
unbelievable seems thank you he said we
want it accessible on PC yeah no problem
loves yeah we got this they said it
could never be done well here it is done
so when you first get on the game this
is what you see right wants me to do a
battle gallic get in boom boom boom
you're done Wow one of them's dead
so confusion right now into the next
ones this one no that one no that one
boom thank you goodbye
announce the final bit you're both gonna
burn see ya let's go to the portal see
what this does I'm gonna summon
something for five hundred oh cool okay
so now I'm this guy and then the cool
thing is when you get back you can just
take a look around your champion take
Brian look at that is all right Bri so
mazzani's Peter look at that this is
good on phone so I think it's gonna look
amazing on PC so let's see play the game
Brian you can see it's pretty good
progress as well that was just the start
no but you forgot one thing Laurence
what the bottle pass oh yes here season
one is now live life you can win awesome
rewards including free energy refills
gems of gridded artefact sets and new
epic and legendary champions by
fulfilling the daily and weekly
challenges if you want to join me on man
at Lowe's cuz it's not hard so go to the
video description to help the show and
ray chatter legends and if you're a new
player you got a hundred thousand silver
one free energy refill one XP boost and
one free champion this is adjudicator oh
look at that powerful woman I bet your
shoes are right
sassy boss if
I told you to do the dishes you wouldn't
argue would you straight away is that
clean enough that's the only question
I'd be asking and you'll find your extra
Ward's here in your Inbox
to the next 30 days so what you're in
for go to the video description and
download red shadow legends right now on
your mobile for free
[Music]
the problem before we get started
meeting someone's earning money is that
because you've possessed financial
freedom movements it's actually true I
just like you did the old Tyson Fury
thing I went down [__] and I found that
doesn't finance in the tip oh yeah well
it looks like it I mean yeah stole
wasn't the nicest or but I wouldn't call
it at it sure well we go in on Jake you
did actually say on the last podcast
yeah people are a bit harsh on him
yeah that doesn't mean I can't find this
funny yeah no you're allowed to laugh
other people just not in a vicious way
look so nasty we are about to becomes
gonna be bad this financially free they
say were entitled and lazy they tell us
to go to college get a job retire at 65
the first question yeah who was they the
others the ones know anyone retire at 65
how's that working out for us and we
don't know yet your 20 he's a youtuber
who didn't go to college I'm good yeah I
have been to college university as we
call it in the UK it was pretty good I
had a great time how's that working out
for you it's actually you well you used
to degree you've got a job yeah well
work your way up in the career where my
way out just wins going out for you yeah
working my way out solid your [__]
alone night in uni as well tell you that
now our generation is better than us we
deserve better we're smarter so what's
the solution
we need a creative movement for our
generation one that inspires people to
take action to achieve vision be less
concepts that don't mean anything
genuine action achieving dreams why is
he in a log cabin
nothing scream success like a massive
lock and Fleischman he's the youngest
founder of a publicly traded company
why well they've given the game plan
awaits on the board behind that yeah
they coughed up a pony here web design
photographer video editor VJ Brian when
life gives you lemons like [__] videos
this is the website that gives you the
lemonade no you know what I mean don't
you know in a month floor
that's more than Netflix they say we're
entitled lays with entitled and lazy
they say we're entitled and lazy they
tell us to get a job cut go to college
hate sorry they tell us to go to college
get a job and retire at 65 well how's
that working out for us what if you're
65 we'll be working out Jake still have
no idea what the [__] were being sold
should we just buy it that's a lot of
money to spend there was $19 we
responsible rate this we tried to pivot
our registration is $39.99
okay yeah your details okay well thank
you my dear
Lawrence McKenna quit your job and fire
your boss or quit school because you've
been lied to the system is broken ask
yourself why they're teenagers making
millions of dollars and broke 40 and 50
year olds because times have changed
also because sometimes the economy has
poor people and rich people and young
people sometimes can capitalize on
things that are changing quickly too
early if your parents are poor it's
harder it's wrong but it's harder yeah
let me have a hurry folks I'm feeling
successful this is a success harrybo
okay next slide right next slide we're
on our way to financial freedom little
service for giving away all their
secrets money-making machines hi I'd
like to buy my machine so much so many
ways to make money now and so many
different like websites that touch of
the nose right I've been watching a
little bit of the believing Bruce
YouTube channel who's expert body
language guys that touch of the nose is
not it's never a good look like that but
you know you're talking about that this
I'm concerned yeah good video editor and
it's so tough so far we've heard you can
become a video editor right that is
basically what we've got yeah there's
just such a need for videographers and
video editors so sometimes you don't
have to be the videographer you might
just be a video editor okay ah you can
record videos and then edit god this is
this is not stuff yeah there's something
that can generate it's a high paying job
yeah like there's people making 100 200
300 bucks an hour for these things the
point that they made was like you're
gonna be basically a millionaire the
stylist and now they start by saying
well you could edit videos for like $300
an hour and if you do that for long
enough say to the age of 65 you will be
a millionaire you're going to have to
buy a camera you're going to have to buy
a camera record video and then edit the
video then take that camera and go shoot
go develop relationships go start to get
booked for doing these for doing these
jobs and I really wouldn't die cuz there
are impressionable people out there who
will buy this and who will really be
having their notepad out and go
step-by-step I just made my notes here
by camera shoot stuff we use camera vine
he didn't specifically say shoot
services use the camera what he said is
you'll you'll be booked for jobs and I'm
literally thinking that is so vague like
what what am i shooting but the jobs
the point I'm saying is if you're gonna
charge people in 1989 you can't get up
there with stuff written down on a board
and ad-lib like this [__] needs to be
formulaic
it needs to be really like thought
through and pretty but these two are
riffing here so if you were a
videographer photographer anywhere in
the world how would you get started I
wouldn't I would literally go like film
I like this kid but this is just not
it's not good oh my god how would you
want to guest artists boxer I punch I
punch a little these are just examples
whatever the skill is that you have
there's ways to make money you can be a
tattoo artist the fact that this whole
thing was becoming a millionaire and
then they're telling me become a tattoo
artist any of these skills that you like
or you can think of yes so I think
personal training is a huge one in my
experience if there's one thing the
world doesn't need its [__] personal
trainers yeah there's enough of them
there's more personal trainers in the
gyms then there are people popping
training in the gym trainers bumping
into each other going can I do your free
lesson I was gonna see the same thing
pop everyone eats food yes so there's
needs to be a chef to make that food and
if it's something you're interested in
then again it's like I'm a chef I'm a
chef now I'm a chef here's the problem
right we've signed up for a course from
a youtuber but the thing is he's
actually employed supposedly like
skilled people to help them along with
this I thought this would be more well
put together I thought some company had
gone down more when look we'll do
everything uh-huh you come along you say
the words you act like you [__] care
and we'll pay it the kickback for being
involved this just look like it's being
well thought out were told to sit
there's this girl and here in LA and all
she would do is make a bunch of meals
and package them up into containers and
like pit and then give them out to
people hello I've got a meal for you why
would I take this meal well I'm a chef
are you a qualified chef I'm a chef look
I've got a ha
people want healthy food people want to
be people want the creams fresh feels
that that convenience and so you can
build a simple business out of making a
bulk amounts of food packaging it and
then dropping it off at people's front
doors come on someone's left me a
takeaway here this is the guy wait wait
do you order anything no did you know
it's the guy at the bottom of the garden
path guide I'm a chef you can pay me if
you like it a lot of times people create
artwork but they don't know how to make
money from it how would you stay so
start getting your art into money how
he's gonna make this into a money-making
scheme I'm interested I was like I made
bought it's it's it's hard yeah you know
the rules are sleeves I'm not a body
language expert this roll of the sleeve
is the biggest I haven't got a [__]
clue what to say
body language saying it's interesting
because the artist things like so
different but it's perception there are
is perception so if you're perceived
like your art is worth so much money
and and you know you you carry yourself
in that sort of way I've got to give
credit right that's [__] özgür Jake
Paul is right up there with one of the
best this is amazing the fact that he
even or is perception yeah they started
going on about basically if you perceive
your ought to be worth a lot of money
other people will do to be fair like
that's actually true not it's full of
[__] as this is I don't know how we made
it through that no he's a politician
outside of that Jake Paul also commented
on ksi well I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna
knock this get out in the first round
okay so you want you want revenge for
your brother 100% has to avenge a family
name but chaos I bro I know you're gonna
be watching this
stop being an embarrassment you said
you'd fight me after the face-off I'm
ready for that yeah I want to see it the
faceoff sold it actually the whole
inverses game and then if he beats Gary
gets the fight that's what we want to
see if I let WrestleMania it actually
only youtuber fight I give a [__] about
anything else bear won yeah I have you
heard you had a beef with them Zane from
one direction go on drama what I love
about this video that the title is Zane
versus Logan Paul fight for it so you're
thinking the Scott
yeah they got on camera a fan right
basically it's a login on one side of a
doll and then Zayin from one direction
who won't come out shouting from the
other side of the doll that's the fight
footage we got you what why Jake tweeted
something out because they didn't give
him like props yeah so then Jake tree
that's in uh I could slap this guy right
and then he's hiding on the other side
of the door like her Jimmy wish she
could slap me or lucky I don't come out
and beat the [__] yeah but I'm
currently lucky myself in here for your
for your safety yeah yeah for you me jig
shouldn't have threatened him on social
but in reality that it did happen like
Jake would beat the hell out of this
little things in pretty good shape there
Brian those aren't just disco muscles
and his name he sounds like a bit of an
object so it Lovins me like just totals
for a second yeah it is I and as I
bought partly Logan said Jake needs
something and I hate that I've got to
say this boy he needs his talk you're
like he needs to calm the [__] down sort
of this what he said what he basically
means is he needs a moment which sort of
bolts him out of that gets him out of
Italy when you're a successful person at
every point in everyone's life when
they're very successful they need that
moment where they go you're not Superman
like you can still [__] up you know what
I mean big time
yeah so hopefully he comes back down to
Planet Earth yeah but not with a suicide
forest kind of moment I hope I hope
suggesting my problem is the one when
you're flying high it's something it
takes a hard punch to the face
maybe JJ could help with that Yeah right
do you remember our old friend roadie TV
I do
if you don't he has a very fast montage
Brodie's done it again you've not seen
the set of you know what is this so
broad he went to VidCon which obviously
a huge event and when they're on stage
he has a word with the guy backstage
they look can I ask my girlfriend
something you know where this is going
well this is where no gosh reaction and
he finally drops the bomb that he's
lying honestly you could hear a [__]
pin drop imagine being the artist
sitting there and you let a guy come up
onstage who's gonna need to my
girlfriend something and then he's got
up on stage and go I'm coming out as
transgender you can't throw this guy off
stage at this point you know my favorite
bit about it right just check how long
before he stops how long he lets people
clap for okay he doesn't interrupt these
that he's really lapping this up
so here's the actual foot he's actually
videoed it himself
[Music]
I think it upset this person to stop
guitar VidCon video coming soon now
before I get onto that we have to
mention Jeff Station now finally of the
week's putting up this [__] YouTube has
decided to demagnetize his channel good
news also great news is dropping that in
there a real piece of [__] as finally
had his channel demonetised and he's
taking a break to those two factors
coincide you think so yeah I don't when
I can't make money for being an [__]
I'm less likely to be an [__] I need
to take a break from YouTube I just need
I just need a stop all social media I'm
on this new thing where I'm trying not
the sort of being being ourselves I'm
trying to be above there and I'm trying
not to sort of have a go at people on
social media cuz I don't agree with it
yeah I think having a laugh is fine sure
he's trying to pay themselves out to be
the victim of all of this that he's
brought on himself because he's acting
like a [__] what the problem with
YouTube is it rewards this for him you
have seen so if he just gets out of it
he might actually become a better person
maybe he's not a [__]
but he's acted like a [__] so therefore
if he stops being one then he may not
actually be one great that yeah yeah for
the other mr. station we hope you're
okay you know what I think it's time for
a celebration
[Music]
2news needs to be more like this this is
what it would be like if you and I were
and I'm gonna make a wild jump here for
you I was gonna say gay but fair enough
she's a nice kid I know my PT just loves
the police he's an off-duty police
officer yeah that's him by thought yeah
this guy could just be a very camp
straight guy would become what it was
VidCon season in London again a bigger
small craters make their way to the big
city to interact with each other I
created a trash the stage to give out
his message now I'm not going to name
this individual from now on I've got to
refer to him as mr. [__] it turns out
he's Canadian what is it lady with this
Canadian craters first you got James
Station
then Daniel minecraft man and are this
what sounds a bit xenophobic to me here
yeah what is it with all these Canadians
oh they're all have let go what people
is a bit harsh to generalize Canadians
nobody's doing a bit those needles any
can give it as well as he can take it
you know no did anything in three months
it obviously wants people to give him
publicity so those people would talk
about it that's generally how publicity
works isn't it I just don't get I don't
get what his argument is where he's like
what he's basically trying to say is
Brody does stuff for shock value that's
kind of Brody's thing if I'm completely
honest I don't think of three months
break hasn't anything to do with you no
shock value though yeah and being the
Lizzy little [__] upload more Brody
Brody told us he would be in an LA
mansion by this point this year bro next
year I'm gonna be an LA man Brian
sitting there going he told me a year
after the hundred K he would be at 2
million that was content seems to be a
variety of pranks of their own degree of
cringe but one video stuck out the most
and I was pretended to be gay at the
Pride Parade why do you think that
wanted about the most maybe he knows his
audience
or maybe he's this upset by that because
maybe this guy might be gay I don't know
make any assumptions but I feel like he
might have an inkling and I'm not saying
that in a mean way I'm not saying that
in a mean way no I mean that I know
seriously I mean that what the [__] that
it's the faucet he might be gay that
just makes me just one of those things
might be you're just jumping to
conclusions there no I said I want to
make unique and I don't make any
assumptions I might be gay and that's
why it might have jumped out to him
these are the ok of the video are
pixelated attract so he doesn't
I love how he says our pixelated the
[__] so he doesn't come expect this guy
these are little on the aggressive is
his deliveries a little wouldn't sure
it's like someone's thrown a [__]
wardrobe in the room and gone tell it to
do that he has a point in some of the
things you say yeah sure
appear to be trans folk homophobic and
making people feel less safer convention
Brody is exploiting the fact that people
will clap for things at a concert and
then go in I'm coming out as trans
everyone claps he doesn't go trans
people are disgusting he just goes I'm
only kidding and everyone goes oh and
the reason there's anger here is because
the people clapping felt stupid because
he saw easily manipulated them to do
whatever the hell he wanted yeah just by
seeing the symbol so people clapped and
you mislead them and people aren't going
about that I don't because that means
he's transphobic what he's exploiting is
a social trope right now which is if you
say something which is consider free
coming out for example then ever more
people root for you yeah it's exploiting
what people expect and then Brody's
going notch him a dick here's the thing
what he's actually done is shown that
VidCon is trans friendly because
everyone applauded when he said he
welded cotton and then he went I'm not
trans and everyone went boo can I just
say if I get up there with this Pongal
I'm straight with a abou me no that's
okay because VidCon is not hetero phobic
that's all : it's not phobic of anything
but you can't have it cause no I'd
rather stick pins in your eyes what
about that young kid who went viral
forgetting bullies so for those who
don't know and I mean literally this is
the oldest news right now little Quaid
and Bill was in his his car and his he's
crying being bullied at school it's
obvious he's a little guy god bless it
and his mother's recording saying you
know this is what bullying does it was
all right because you're like I I feel
that she's trying to get across the pain
bullying causes and she's like we're at
a point now where this is my warning
hall to stop the bullying problem is
that's not the case you wonder why kids
are killing themselves
came in right now
you're so old no not mean hard so if
that clip is true so here's what happens
right the internet does what the
internet does sort so this helped
GoFundMe yeah a hundred to thousands of
dollars were raised they were like oh
let's send him to Disneyland or whatever
apparently Oh apparently he's rejected
it I don't know what don't just see that
in the hood yeah I mean I wonder why I
project it look at those little socks on
him why I don't know why he gets me you
know the full story here I mean I don't
really but the point is he's got little
socks like slide yeah am I wrong here I
thought this kid this was a prank it
isn't a Pronger to real month I thought
this was actually nineteen years old
he's not though this is this is the
problem of the Internet
there's that much fake news goes around
you don't know what's realistic that's
why he learns to find out the truth so
he took some other photographs where it
made him look like a baller wise a nine
year old I donate Ian's first Maeby's
cousin when I was it wasn't that long
ago yeah you don't involve nine year
olds yes I must admit this does make me
wary of yeah the whole thing is I don't
know what to believe
extra model slush influencer okay let me
show you this all right can we turn this
down I make a copyrighted yeah well he
just looked badass there doesn't he he
looks not that looks good doesn't it he
looks gangsta they have Steph Curry's
looking good Oh No
well he didn't really see it today
heartbroken yeah cuz you like his little
socks I am unsure what to think about
this because obviously if he's young he
might have just been listening to a few
too many ice cubes oh you don't put that
on line says it don't put that on line
she's been filming him too much doesn't
she it's awesome
there's something going on here and I
don't know what it is but she's why I
don't want to get just a conspiracy
theory apparently his mom he's mom has
research she shut down all their social
media sites at night so so apparently
they're covering
like no you keep the money we don't want
to be bothered anymore I don't think she
realized just how viral this would go
yeah this is the thing though right
she wanted him to be a social media
superstar careful what you wish for I
think this is just one that we've got to
chop up to anyone's guess really feel
like we've let you guys down nine and we
pride ourselves on delivering the news
in a truthful way but some stories you
just can't get to the bottom of not yet
anyway and when you've got that fella
from the NYPD yeah exactly
got the bottom of anything is either a
bit of a beef with that old okay my
fella T food tyrion lanister t foo ninja
got hacked the hacker challenged Sifu oh
and then I think T food challenge him
back in which case enjoys like nah me
I'm looking for you yeah cuz it was a
hacker yeah but see what you see yeah
sure alright yeah I woke up this morning
to a whole bunch of heat on Twitter I
guess supposedly ninja called me out
challenged me to our fight did he
mention this guy to you what are you
most yeah yeah he said that T foo guy
and I went bless you and he said that
seafood guy or hate him and then we did
the podcast me didn't mention it
deliberately yeah he went don't say that
on the podcast though because I hate
snow I'm talking about him cuz I'm
really powerful and cool and I hate it
if this dick said something yeah I never
mentioned this to anyone before but he
actually did try to get me permanently
banned behind my back try to literally
ruin my career and honestly I should
have called him out then for some reason
I didn't I just let it slide but like I
don't know why I didn't to really try to
get a bug no that's like top of the list
of didn't [__] happen yeah ever when
you're that successful you don't give a
[__] about what other people are doing
realistically actual at night kind of
sucks now to [__] up and enjoy replied I
actually have been enjoying the game
recently after they've gotten Gotham
City up there if you didn't enjoy the
game stop playing it in Rossing all the
time
zing you've killed him I don't think
he's that isn't that like that's pretty
nasty bro but that's a low blow
yeah he literally just said if you don't
like the game don't play the game and
this foods not very nice
oh don't eat it then well you want to
fight I'm getting the opportunity now to
try to tear me down in the ring
okay UFC MMA whatever the ksi Logan Paul
it went down it went well like why don't
we do it like let's run it like I'm not
scared if anything he's scared you know
I'm saying let's be honest right this
guy's in decent shape but Ninja is not a
[__] fight he's he's a ninja like the
point is this bit of a geek
yeah is a gamer barely works out like
what is killing the game financially
he's top of the game in gaming so you're
just saying like I can't beat what
you've done in the gaming world so I
just want to fight yeah but he's a ninja
and March only just come in any actually
new console yeah random does all that
[__]
Karate Kid kicked them straight at the
head you know nor can defend that Steve
saw so Amber Rose has always been super
hot in your mind not my mind yeah Amber
Rose was Kanye West misses for a period
of time before he went with Kim
Kardashian she was really popular
because she was just like wild woman
with the wild guy yeah and he wrote a
lot of very sexy sounds and then she got
was Wiz Khalifa and had a couple of kids
with Wiz Khalifa she just like rappers
wow she's wet and got a [__] head
tattoo yeah our kids names I don't want
to like character assassinate people you
know I wouldn't recommend anyone get the
words bash or hash but I can't believe
that this is their [__] names I don't
think those are their names though are
their beauty is not what's on the
outside said the person who was a model
it's what's on the inside that counts
inside of my [__] and inside of my
heart
Wow what's usually inside your [__]
love I mean a baby roll robbers well the
baby came out of a [__] it was bash or
hash the people that are telling me I'm
too pretty for a faced at are the same
people that would tell me that I'm too
pretty even if they thought it was ugly
and lie to me lull or they would just
tell me I'm ugly
so either way the moral of the story is
do whatever the [__] you want in life I
wouldn't say nothing whatever you want
in life no I'm not saying she was too
pretty for a tight you know I just think
if you need to look in the mirror to
remember your kids names and you
probably shouldn't have them I've left
my kids somewhere what are their names
read my forehead I'm not saying she
can't get a face like no she has the
full [__] forehead it's a bit extreme
in it I just don't get it you know face
tattoos you either need to go all-in or
not at all nor nor your door so amber
you need to get more face tattoos
alright get a couple more you know bash
hash slash trash mash sash
cash - everything across your forehead
and that's good
I think first up news is one of the
Fudd's that's going to be the most
regretable in future
yeah it's that on your forehead well
it's not the first thing I've heard of
my face love thing is you can wipe that
off yeah so this is like the biggest
ASMR channel I think keep GB I think
she's called she does this thing where
she just like this is the thing about
ASMR let me tell you about your mom yeah
you know and she can never Shout do you
think if she argues when they're arguing
she goes [__] up our date tonight I
don't even want caramel anymore right if
we're watching with butchering this we'd
love to have you on the podcast we'd
love to do a whole podcast going out
January I'd like to do an ASMR podcast
at some point well it'd be cool because
I bet you they go through all sorts of
weird stuff that we'd never know about
do you think she cries quiet let's let's
be honest right people go to sleep like
watching her yeah sure they sleep after
what they mostly finished watching you
know and I'm sure just as part of the
criteria womankind
it's like a caring nature like yeah I'm
caring about you that's the feeling like
okay you want someone who loves you
basically you fall asleep you don't feel
loved do you want to feel loved and she
makes you feel loved there's but close
to home is that it yeah but close to
hormetic my name is GP and welcome back
to my channel
I find her voice so soothing straight
off the belt do you think you have a
crush on her
no no no this platonic like I don't mean
this disrespect for them she doesn't
find me attractive
but the point is I don't look at her in
that way like I say it's exist
it's like a friendly vibe she's not
putting out sexual advances she's just
on the other end of a screen minding her
own business making lovely noises and I
happen to be listening yeah do you think
when she has said she's like oh that's
really good I don't know okay well we
don't need to guess you know what it is
long as my chalky you can't kind of
shock you yet I'd never thought of it
Wow okay so this woman it's a lovely
little woman you see she's talking or
soon Lawrence let's get tucked in let's
tuck in
are you ready for bed now
I like being coal people do not like
that I feel like we're a baby in a pram
maybe we are maybe maybe we're just
young babies enterprise do you go hello
no I don't
okay feels so nice to think into this is
freaking me out
her voice is lovely I feel like she's
really invading my personal space like I
feel like I'm like because that's what
you do when you talk someone in [__]
yeah back off
leave her alone back off I can tuck
myself in you know she's got the real
mumsy vibe she took on us in we're all
happy about it we're just two little
brothers ya know do it do it mom
go back to carnation squeeze no I want
top in yeah that if he doesn't want to
talk then he shouldn't have got into bed
yeah what a weird set of twins
what would you do if you were to do an
ASMR channel I quite like this one
there's sweeping mines I iconic Mustang
it's weird how Susan the scissors and
that's not because it isn't a beautiful
car as well this is just like the car
can I just say this there was a man who
was in his house and suddenly just sees
this woman walk up the drive in high
heels put a camera down and just start
filming he's just going Sandra
there's a woman out there scraping her
nails along the Mustangs scraping her
nails
oh my 2016 Ford Mustang she goes oh she
back again can you do me a favor yeah
such vampire yes amar I wonder if any of
them addressed it was [__] I like women
who are vampire that's not a sexual
thing it's just something I think looks
cool
Oh like they look hot okay measuring you
for feeding Wow you can be longtime
rodent yeah well no no I was thinking
that was making a joke quite dick well
she's got the funds and it does say
[__] vampire when she was getting you
the vampire do you think she's gonna
dress up in like um I don't think the
funds will look so real right they look
really real them
expecting why is it just like you didn't
Matt sexy the fun cool on the are they
yeah bite me bite me I just want to see
if this person is still going the
Valentine's Day breakfast food he is
exactly who I expect over 100 Zach yeah
some sort of evil genius baby of course
why else would she be with it why else
would you be with me you know and keep
our hands gonna put that on my baby yeah
I'm gonna put I'm gonna pop that down on
a bet on Bob yeah because you might
bacon you know I'm saying you ready for
that baby you ready for that Valentine's
dick you got planned we've gone to your
favorite place baby we want a warm
Walmart all local all the food and drink
that you like baby we're gonna get a 50
pound lobster a 60 pound lobster
anything you'll be an easy as a man who
likes thick women yeah you mean a bigger
women not women who aren't smart it's
hard not to get sort of imagine how
excited this guy gets with her yes
there's no lag on this side of the table
you know that it's the way he was
looking about her like you did like calm
tone bro yeah I their families probably
watch this and go per family are well
used to this it's his family I'm more
interested in when he goes like yeah I
got a girlfriend whatever and they find
out and they start like watching her
just guzzle down lobster and the video
by the way starts hello they come they
go David
what are you doing it's just I thought
this is a it's a bit different yeah it's
it's it's hard to explain why can't you
find yourself a nice southern girl to a
family who are like YouTube savvy it
must be really strange it's not like
she's sitting there giving her opinions
about like you know what's happening in
modern day culture
she is just gobbling did you ever see
the Toby had money
[Music]
by the way this is their sister as well
signe yeah what a family I just it was
Talia mom a car cooler looks and then
look on this videos really it is fun you
smashed it so I'm morally dead destined
for greatness back in school days I was
known for my lateness always wanted more
wouldn't ever tried to take this always
been the world I never left the fakeness
can I just say yeah Marnie's voice is
actually like good yeah in terms of like
a wrong like Toby's well not but I think
money's is better
North on story oh I don't know about
that Toby's probably my favorite side
man I said it I'll just let it I do like
the way they're coming button forward on
this law it made it a bit more
interesting yeah we roll around imagine
this if you want to go abroad just pay
for six I love things like that with it
it sounds a little bit Lonely Island if
we want to go aboard we just pray for
trips I'm like yes that's how everyone
there ugly bloody good they pay for
their children they can afford to do
though yes we it's very literal pay for
the games know that games pay me or your
girl got you from I got mine for free
about him raise all you say for the
games and now they pay they pay me I'm
like that is a good line that's I
getting sponsored by someone that you
dream of getting sponsored by I like
that's the what I watch is what I
thought is there like obviously Bona
made this sisters also singing yeah not
Talia mom the parents must be like look
what we did
we've got yeah destined for greatness
they look over at JJ's parents in church
and go well yeah the last out of a lot
of our boys wrap together yeah how's
tank by the way we've made it to that
time now we're in the video Brian and I
go back and we watch a kid eat food and
I've thought Spock are similar we're not
bullying him he's in on it if anything
and it's affectionate I do think that
people are miss placing like net jostles
yeah like a bit of a bit of joking on to
bullying yeah because this is this is
where you become a social justice
warrior
you sit the [__] down yeah I genuinely
love Tyler yes you do you never lose why
yes I talk more than the pie that food
today we're on the new cheddar bacon
King into it you know is right when I
say his little face I just think I
missed you
yeah have you spoken and then I think I
miss you yeah he looks a bit like a bird
today but I don't know why I don't know
where you go with this book so per usual
with these bacon kings this thing is
freaking massive
what do you reckon I think sorry yeah I
think he's gonna say it's okay I don't
think he's gonna be blown away
oh nice big bite big by how many bites
you soon before we go root I think to
actually this looks like I'm 1/3 Wow
we're on one one Feldon swallowed up the
other Lansbury's looked up there's the
second one
Wow okay that's just what I want is
another bye before he finishes boy
swallows are one of one more bite are
they and so nigh on it's no more yeah so
I know my food review uh how long we
been watching this guy for two years
three years I've seen him have ketchup a
lot like a million time yeah I never
really liked it it's a bit like what he
didn't like syrup on his yeah or butter
Punk remember that yeah and as pocket
food I'm not really a big fan of it
dairy like syrup just poured the whole
thing on there we go alright guys so the
bacon the cheddar cheddar bacon King
from BK I'm gonna go ahead and say it's
kind of like in the middle of nada
by-and-by I'm pretty sure that between
us we were accurate there he went
it's alright I said he thought would be
okay been amazing I feel a 500 turn in
my head
max if you're watching Tyler could you
put a number out of 10 on all your foods
and future because we really need a
scale like a buy or not a body is just
not enough for me it's free it's very
binary I need like ratings I called it
he literally has proven me bang on yeah
and it looks that way as well thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
hit that like button down there a shadow
legends it helps us make more of these
generally we need that so yeah